[Applause]
qatar is getting used to safely hosting
major sporting events during the
pandemic at the end of last year the
country was home to teams from all over
asia
for the final stages of the champions
league
and this club world cup is another big
step for qatar in the build-up to the
main event
next year's world cup this is the second
edition of the fifa club world cup that
we host
however today we're hosting it in
completely different circumstances
we're hosting it during the global
pandemic
of the coronavirus which is obviously
very difficult
but it is also important for us to make
sure we play our part for the safe
return
of football three continental title
winners are already in qatar
all players and staff were tested for
coronavirus before their journey began
and on arrival in doha the teams then
enter a biosecure environment
which includes their hotel training
ground and stadiums
qatar's league champions aldu hale play
al-ashley of
egypt on thursday the winners of that
game get to take on bayern munich
in the semi-finals of course we cannot
travel like before we cannot
walk like before we need to take care
about um
ourselves to take the social distances
so it's not it's not easy but um anyway
we cannot complain
we are lucky to um to play with uh maybe
10 15 20 000 people
is not the case in europe so we are
lucky
stadiums will be at 30 capacity with
three categories of fans allowed to
attend
those that have had the kovid 19 vaccine
those that test negative just ahead of
the match
all those that have had and recovered
from the virus in the last four months
a lot of evidence internationally and
even locally
that those who have contracted the
disease
are immune from the secondary infection
until now we know definitely for six
months and
in some evidences it lasts up to nine
months even
so we've taken more uh restrictive
measures and we said only four months
the hope is that next year's world cup
will be in a post-pandemic environment
but qatar says it's ready for any
eventuality
andy richardson al jazeera doha